[Music]
Cactus is not just a symbolic plant in
Mexico it's more than that
you'll need to irrigate it you don't
need to rely on rains we could make a
material out of it that would be
fantastic we thought
[Music]
according to the UN the fashion industry
accounts for eight to ten percent of
global carbon emissions
and nearly 20 percent of Wastewater
this is Adrian and Marte these two
Mexican entrepreneurs set out with the
purpose of reducing the environmental
impact created by animal leather
production and to find a sustainable
alternative
[Music]
we specialize in developing biomaterials
that can be applied in a wide range of
products from Footwear to garments
accessories
the Certo is not leather desert is not a
synthetic desert is a new material it's
a new innovation made of cactus
the cactus Nobles is in our national
flag in our Hispanic culture we had this
dream of making a material out of a
symbolic plant of Mexico something that
we can all identify with
there are more than 1 000 species of
cactus around the world and most of them
are here in Mexico so this plant is not
just like a symbolic plant of the
country it's more than that it's a it's
a plant that generates thousands and
thousands of jobs around the country
so Cactus is an agroscopic plant it
means that it plant absorb the humidity
from the environment the skin of the
plant itself is very resistant and
intelligent it grows without irrigation
without herbicide pesticides without any
special care and even if it doesn't rain
through the whole year it will still
grow strong that's proof of how
resilient and efficient it is
it only takes one year until you reach
the point of harvest and this is about
the size that we wanted to be at when we
cut it when we Harvest it to process
we dry it in the sun for three days and
then it's ready to start the meshing
process we do an extraction of proteins
and fibers and which is then transformed
into a sort of liquid paste and then
this is coated on a base which is
normally a recycled polyester recycled
cotton or a mix of this so we can give
the material of different technical
Behavior
this is the natural color of cactus
without any additional coloring
filling and the touch and the color is
very similar to leather but without
being from animals
currently the certo's biggest Market is
fashion industry the first one was with
fossil for making bags and accessories
then we did a collaboration with h m
then with Adidas boxing
then we did with car lager field and we
are working on very promising projects
in the automotive industry
now more than ever and consumers are
more conscious of the environmental
impact of their choices they want to
reduce their carbon footprint in this
world
[Music]
that's why since we start the company we
decide to offer this material not just
to the big Brands but to everybody
because we know that sustainability
should not be exclusive
we are growing in a resilient way we are
growing in a sustainable way
the technology that we are putting into
these Farms opens the door to many
possibilities of innovating from cactus
in pharmaceutics cosmetics
so the journey is just beginning and the
future is very very exciting
[Music]